>> How is JSConf so far?
My name is Maximiliano, a long name - Max
is fine, I can go by Max.
I'm a mobile web developer, been doing web
development since browser since 1995.
I'm travelling a lot for training and consulting.
I'm from Buenos Aires.
I've authored a couple of books, the last
two on web performance.
I'm not here to talk about myself about how
the system is broke.
For example, this is my phone this morning.
It's trying to update 231 apps, okay?
So I encourage you to do the same thing, disable
automatic updates and see what happens.
Also you've probably heard about the news
in the last few months, apps currently sending
a lot of data to different servers, sending
your data when Super League, not just on iOS
but also on Android, and, again, because I'm
travelling a lot, I flew here through New
York because I had a flight cancellation,
and I saw that in Manhattan, in Penn Station
in downtown Manhattan, download the app for
the train station.
Do we need an app for the train station?
If you go to the store, it's 50 megabytes
for the train station app.
Reviews are pretty bad, okay?
And it's not just that app, okay.
So this is a common scenario.
We see this every day.
You're thinking well, PWAs, right?
PWAs should be the answer for a lot of these
apps, okay?
That is why today I'm starting a new Twitter
account.
It should be a PWA, okay?
That's for real.
[Applause].
@shouldbePWA.
They show a lot of apps out there that should
be based on the web platform.
There's no need for an app.
Progressive web apps, don't ask me nor a definition.
How many of you have created PWAs?
Let's see.
Around 30 per cent.
How many of you are working on the web?
Most of you, right?
So it basically is the same, so why 70 per
cent of you are not saying that you're creating
PWAs?
So I offer this article in Net - I authored
this article in .net magazine.
I like this definition that PWA is the current
- it's basically the web.
Just for the zero per cent of you if you've
not heard about this, it's a web app with
service workers, and with, let's say, an optional
layer that has to do with distribution, how
users will install or use the app, because
installation is not mandatory, you use the
web app from the browser.
So right now, today, 81 per cent of your users
are able to install a PWA from the browser
they're actually using to access your websites.
It's a lot.
On mobile, it's 92, okay?
On desktop, it's 69.
These numbers are getting higher every day.
So this is the support on mobile.
It works on every browser when you're in a
website, you can actually install it from
your home screen.
That's the JSConf PWA, and then you have an
app.
That app looks like any other app on Android,
okay?
You have seen this before, probably.
So that is I think pretty cool.
It looks like any other app on Android.
The same happens on iOS.
You can go to Tinder, you know that one?
Tinder is a PWA, you can go to your iPhone,
go to the share sheet and the home screen,
create an icon.
You're thinking that's not a PWA, it's just
a short cut to the website.
If you open that icon, you have a standalone
fuel-screen experience from looks like any
other app on the iPhone.
So it's basically a PWA.
Then you have - feature phones, I have this
Nokia here with me, feature phones, non-touch,
they're supporting PWAs.
But it's not just on mobile.
On desktop you can go and install Trivago,
Tinder, by the way, and you have a - that
works on Windows, Chromebook, Mac and Linux.
You can open more PWAs at the same time.
We have the properly, we just need to create
really, really good experiences, and today,
let's say that I can say that maybe half of
the PWA s out there on R offering a good experience.
The other half are away for offering a competition
like the native apps, and so we will try to
see why, and what we can do today to improve
that experience.
So, talking about the app cycle, okay?
So because we are creating apps, not just
websites that will appear in the browser.
So, when you open a PWA, so if the app loads
like any other content.
That's not, that's no surprise.
What happens when the user goes to the background
such as pressing the home screen?
You have visibility change event, and there
you can pause a game or an animation, you
can stop a timer, okay, because you're not
in the foreground any more.
A couple of seconds later, mostly on mobile
devices such as Android, the app might be
suspended, and there is a new freeze event
which means your app will be in memory for
a while but you won't be executing any code.
If you want to save the state or do something,
this is your last dinner.
The freeze event.
And then you go back to the app.
If you're lucky enough, the app is still in
memory and now resume will be executed, and
also the visibility change again.
Let's say that, when you close the PWA, you
are using an intention app like recording
a video, watching a Netflix movie, or using
a 3D game, when you go back, your app was
discarded from memory, so in this case, the
PWA will start from scratch like a normal
load but there is now a new boolean value
that you can query that will give you true,
okay, in that case, and there you have the
opportunity to load again the state, the previous
state that you saved before, okay?
You need to start doing this.
So, what about iOS?
iOS isn't following exactly this rule.
In fact, I did a research on the life cycle
of an iOS PWA and it looks like this.
So, anyway, the important part here is that
here in the PWA and iOS, you can zoom in,
control, click, type on a form, so that is
the current state.
When you get out of the PWA, okay, your app
is current ly frozen, so, when you go back
you can see a splash, so it's like starting
from a crash but the WebKit is restoring the
state.
If you kill the app, it also restores the
state, so there is no way to restart the app
from the scratch.
You can buy a new iPhone if you want!
At least you can restart the phone.
That's a problem.
If you have an invalid state, there's no way
to get out of that.
It's a good idea on iOS at least to provide
a reload action within the UI at least until
Apple changes this.
Also, you can provide full navigation like
a back button.
We have gestures like swipe to go back but
it's a good idea to be sure you want for this.
So what about the resources?
Worker is the one that is storing and saving,
and serving those files.
So - service worker.
The problem is that there are situations where
you can find this.
You open up an app, and Uber in this case,
Chrome, is saying I don't have the files.
It's saying how is that possible?
Because the browser can't delete the files
if there is a storage pressure, so no more
space on that device, unless you request for
persistent storage, so this is something you
need to do explicitly, right?
It's a promise API, so you just ask for persistent
storage so your files will be there.
Now let's move to another topic.
This is programme aggressive experience.
Star, we have been creating one app for all.
So create an app, need JS, Vue, Angular, whatever,
we have a lot of devices, high-end 15s, low-end
phones, feature phones that might be running
your app, and we have different bandwidth
and latencies.
I'm here with a 4G device on roaming, and
it looks like a slow 3G, okay?
I know, so maybe you have a Samsung, S10 with
the best LTE plus, plus super ultra but four
per cent of battery.
I need something from your web app but I don't
want you to load those four megabytes of JavaScript,
so what I'm saying is maybe we need to copy
something from YouTube?
It has a model for users.
It's trying to guess the best possible experience
for that user, and it is on quality.
The user can change that.
Why can't we do the same on our PWA, there
are a lot that those about the context, the
perform servers, device memory API, so you
can gather information that scenario so you
can make some decisions.
Also, there is a reporting API available today.
It's an HTTP header where you send an end
point or URL and the browser will send you
for that particular user with real user metrics
information reports about performance issues.
On that particular advice, on that particular
network, so then you can make decisions to
keep a consistent experience, because we want
to have a consistent experience, such as changing
the service worker cache policy based on this,
SSR, client-side rendering, you can switch
based on the scenario, reducing the amount
of loaded data, and many other tricks that
you can apply.
So, we want to offer a good experience for
every user.
We are creating PWAs for a real operating
system.
So, we need some kind of platform integration,
so we need to do something else compared with
a normal website.
So, for example, web authentication is really
a good example of how you can improve this
quickly.
Today, for example ... it's a PWA where you
can actually log in pretty quickly with your
current session on Android.
I didn't have an account on that website before,
but with one click, I'm in, okay?
This is coming on Safari as well.
Web share, you're creating an app that is
standalone, so full screen, there is no browser
UI, so how can I get out of my PWA?
How can I get my content out of my PWA?
We can share the content with a very simple
API available right now on iOS, Android, and
some desk tomorrow operating systems.
For example, I'm here on Twitter on iOS, Twitter
PWA, not the native app, and you can just
share from there.
It opens the native share dialogue, so I think
that's pretty cool.
Also, we have a version that is web-share
target API.
I can take a picture from my photos app, and
I can share that picture into the Twitter
PWA, okay?
Directly.
That's the second version of the API that
is currently on Canary.
Talking about Android, for those of you on
Android, we have something known as web ABK.
How many have heard about web ABK.
Oh, I can see no hands at all!
That works on Chrome and Android.
In the cloud, the Play store is scraping the
native Android package format and it is installing
that silently into the device which means,
for example, the JSConf PWA is an Android.
I can go to settings and see it's an Android
app.
It says it was installed from the Play Store
which is false, because it's signed by the
Play Store, and that creates a good first-palace
experience for your Android cruisers.
The same happens on Samsung.
If you're on a Samsung device and using the
internet browser, in this case, a web APK
signed by Samsung apps.
This is interesting because you're now creating
Android-native apps from an Android operating
system point of view.
Talking about desktop, today, on desktop,
you can do multi-window - that is Google drive
on desktop.
It's a PWA.
You can open your window.
So, it's a multi-window world.
You can say on the web, it's multi-tab, but
you need to know what you're going to do with
this.
Now the user can have several apps open.
You can use the service worker, for example,
in the message API to make some kind of control,
and future looks really promising, so let
me show you an early mock on how tab on PWAs
might look like later, might be this year,
I don't know.
This is it from the last Google IO where you
can see it's your app with several tabs inside.
We have a lot of new challenges on the way.
Coming back to the iOS, our last platform
to talk about, let me tell you this: so, if
you Google PWAs on iOS, the first, the second,
and articles there are my articles, okay?
And the snippet you see there, it's also coming
from one of my articles.
There is no documentation at all from Apple
or from the WebKit team.
They are supporting partially, totally, or
the technologies, but there is no documentation,
okay?
You need to be careful, test a lot, and add
some metadata that is required for an iOS
PWA.
Let me tell you one thing only: Apple, shame
on you, right?
Because this is a problem that we have as
a community.
So, installation experience.
So, we are creating apps, okay?
So we want to create apps.
So we need to improve how users will install
our app.
First, because most users will never know
that there is an actual home screen and an
install menu with three little dots, menu
in the browser.
We manage on that, we have this web app service
worker and the distribution rings here.
I did this on purpose.
I didn't set web app manifest on the red ring
because I don't think it's the only one.
Web app manifest is one of the key aspects
of the PWA, of course.
It is the one that will give you on desktop
button in Chrome.
It is giving you the mini info bar on Android,
and on other browsers, it would give you several
budgets when you are PWA, you're passing the
PWA criteria been but I don't think this is
the only important part on a PWA.
You must provide your own install button within
your UI, within your menu, whenever you feel
it's the moment to offer the user installation,
you can actually add your own install button.
So it is simple but weird, okay?
So you need to listen for a new event before
installing prompt.
When the browser thinks that you're passing
a PWA criteria, it will fire that event, so
you need to basically prevent default first,
just to avoid the browser to show its own
banner, and then you want to save that argument
that you receive for later usage.
And then when the user clicks on that button,
you will just call prompt, okay?
So that is roughly how it worked.
You can create your own button that will trigger
the native dialogue on desktop and on Android
devices.
So apart from web app manifests already mentioned,
you need to add iOS metadata, and something
that it's not completely new, but for most
web developers, it's new: an app launcher.
It's a native package that will trigger a
PWA.
I'm not talking about a hybrid like Cordoba,
I'm talking about a launcher that opens the
browser in a special full-screen standalone
mode.
We're not patching our files, our HTML and
JavaScript files, we're not packaging those
files, we're just launching the PWA and the
service worker will take care of the loading
device.
So, for windows, we can create an APPX - that's
the format available - and then you can go
to the Microsoft Store for this Nokia device.
You can create a cash generator - there are
free tools that will help you in the creation
of this - so, again, you still have your web
app, you still have your service workers.
We're talking about the outer ring - just
that.
You need to do something else, not just the
web manifest for these - for these operating
systems.
But you're thinking, "Well, what about Play
Store?
What about Android?."
Let me give you an example, an e-commerce
site from the US where you can buy flowers.
They created a really good PWA.
There were even mentioned in the last Google
IO keynote.
They also used to have a native review, was
kind of okay.
Well [microphone breaking up] Play Store today,
you go to trending, then the fifth one, it's
800 Flowers, and you can install the app from
the Play Store.
That app is basically a PWA, okay?
It's their PWA.
So now they have replaced their native app
with a PWA.
This is now possible, so you can publish new
apps and PWAs, or if you have on your company
crappy Android native app, a package ID, upload
new versions, and all the users will receive
now the PWA version.
From now on, you don't need to upload any
more updates because you just change the files
on your server.
You don't need to package new APKs.
So this is thanks to trusted web activities.
There is something new available on Android
with Chrome, maybe it's going to appear with
other browsers as well.
So far, it's only on Chrome in a will let
you compile your own Android app, need to
use Android Studio, okay?
It's one line of code that you need to set
that is basically your URL.
You need to show you're the owner of that
URL, and, when you do that, you set the icon,
the URL, and you go to the Play Store.
So you can actually today publish PWAs in
the Play Store, okay?
So, what about iOS?
Can we do something for iOS?
Probably you're thinking no?
. Let me tell you I found something, not what
you're expecting anyway.
I found a tool called configurator where you
can actually set web clips for full screen.
That full screen thing there that is basically
a PWA.
This creates a mobile config file that you
can serve on Safari or website and send by
email.
If the user accepts that configuration file
... icons.
This is for enterprise distribution?
It's not for end-users.
For enterprise distribution, this is one way
that you have today to distribute your PWAs.
One tool that is cool and interesting that
you could use today to create these packages
because we are web developers, Android studios
is there, it's kind of tricky to understand
Android Studio and how it works, PWA builder
is a free tool from Microsoft that will help
you create all these packages.
If you already have a PWA, it will create
the AP KFOR the play store, the APPX or Microsoft
Store, and it will even create you a version
for the iOS app store.
Using that case the web use.
It will be like a hybrid for iOS for the app
store.
So we can distribute apps in the store.
But you're thinking but we are the web, we
should not be in the store.
That's a different discussion but, from a
business point of view, it's a good idea to
be there.
But we need to be careful.
Because not every app can be in the store.
For example, there is a PWA today that I'm
not sure if you've heard about, that icon,
how many of you know what that icon is?
Have one here.
Well, that is YouPorn.
They have a PWA, and of course they cannot
be in the store, okay?
Because the store has some rules, and you
need to check those rules.
You cannot publish private apps, apps for
your employee, for example.
You cannot create apps using PayPal or other
mechanisms to sell content, so you need to
check those rules, okay.
So the modern PWA cheat sheet, we have seen
basic PWA support that we need to add, and
then understand the live cycle.
Progressive experience, not the same app for
all the users, and then platform integration,
we need to integrate with every platform,
bugs, hacks, we need to do unfortunately.
Then we need to improve installation experience,
create the install button and also publishing
in the store, okay?
So this is for me what you need to do today
to create a really good PWA, okay?
That is all.
Thank you!
[Applause].